there's a lot of guys that um
have ego investments in certain brands
or even
you know types of food like soy's a big
one you know
in the space that i work in a lot of
guys will
make fun of weaker men and call them soy
like you know you know soy boy or
or something like that and then they'll
always have their vegan counterparts
come in and try to defend soy
um you know with all kinds of narratives
and stories about how
it's not bad for you but throughout your
entire book you talk about soy
in quite great lengths right so yeah
what is the what is the sum of all these
uh parts when it comes to soy like is
soy good or bad for men
well that's a good question i i mean
what's funny about soy
every scientist agrees it acts like
estrogen
so you at least have to start the
conversation there because even the
vegans that say it's good for you
they admit it acts like estrogen so
you know that alone for most men is
enough to say okay i don't want to have
more soy in my food and by the way the
arguments that they tend to push a lot
of is like you'd have to eat
like buckets of soy to convert that much
estrogen in your body for it to be
harmful
is it is it really that much or is it
like sushi
if i put soy like if i dip my mackey
rolls into soy sauce
is that bad enough to disrupt my
endocrine system you know for that day
good question yeah so in canada
ironically they did a food study with
over 100 food items plant foods
and all of the plants were under 1 000
units of estrogen except
soy and flax soy and flax were over 100
000 units of estrogen
so it was like a night and day
difference between soy flax and
everything else
and what was cool about that study they
tested soy sauce so they tested natto
and all these different you know
naturally fermented soy products
all of those were under 100 units of
estrogen
so the actual soy 100 000 even soy
protein was in the thousands right like
a lot of the soy products but as soon as
you
include natural fermentation those
microorganisms chew up all those
estrogens and it depends a lot on your
gut health so if you've got a crappy gut
you know you're those soy estrogens are
going to go into your bloodstream a lot
more have a lot bigger impact if your
gut super healthy
your gut bacteria are probably going to
break a lot of them down it's pretty
risky
and the other thing is there's a more
complicated argument a lot of vegans
will propose at a scientific level where
there's there's actually
when you have testosterone in your body
there's only one receptor it's called
the testosterone receptor
but with estrogen there's actually two
receptors that stick to it
and one's called estrogen receptor alpha
and the other one's called estrogen
receptor beta so alpha beta
and everybody recognizes in the
scientific community alpha is pretty
problematic alpha receptor
increases breast cancer risk in women it
increases prostate cancer in men it's
problematic you don't want to be
activating the alpha receptor
beta receptor is actually protective in
terms of estrogen
so estrogen has a lot of protective
benefits to it if you're activating the
beta receptor it's protective against
prostate cancer it's protective against
breast cancer and a lot of other things
so the argument most vegans like to
propose is that
the soy activates the beta receptor
and they you know michael greger dr
michael greger a big you know
youtube star within the vegan community
he's the big proponent of this argument
and he cites a study that i've looked at
he said look look at figure one
in this paper it shows beta activation
and only a little bit of alpha with soy
what's ironic about that paper is figure
two shows the exact
opposite in a different person so it's
very person dependent
again way too and you know i didn't get
into that much wheat i didn't get into
the weeds that much in my book i tried
to make it really easy for anybody to
read but
yeah if you really if you're really
honest with yourself and you really dig
into the science i mean soy is
estrogenic
it's something people should avoid yeah
and so is uh flaxseed oil which is
something i used to
like routinely blend into my protein
shakes for a long time
um i learned flaxseed was estrogenic
about two years ago so i took that out
on my diet
um you know soy's obviously been out of
my diet for a long time because i knew
that was garbage but um
i mean there's still a lot of soy
products out there and it's infused in a
lot of foods i mean it's a filler in a
lot of foods i mean even mention
um in the book if you buy something that
is labeled vegetable oil 30 of it could
be soy right you know because soy's a
vegetable
so um soy is something like soy is
something that all men should
should skip like is that what you're
saying or correct unless it's fermented
soy sauce fine put a ton of it on your
food
okay so fermented is fine so sushi's
good you're good with your sushi you can
yeah awesome okay all right
[Music]
i don't have to move away from my sushi
place man cause i got this great
boutique joint that does some good
awesome does some good work